we're living in a day where as an
individual as a leader as an
entrepreneur you have access to
extraordinary technologies technologies
that were only available to the largest
companies and governments just 20 years
ago we're in a world where you can touch
impact and sell products to you know
today 2.5 billion in five years seven
billion people all the planet earth is
likely be connected with a megabit
connection the way that you lead the way
that you start companies needs to be
different because your ability to impact
the world is far different your access
to exponential technologies computer's
network censors robotics 3d printing
synthetic biology on the technology
front on the tools front crowdfunding 15
billion dollars per year in 9 2015 up to
100 billion a year by 2020 crowd
sourcing the ability to get access to
any expertise you want and and finally
incentive competitions the ability to
have the crowd help you solve your
problems these are the tools that we
have as leaders today to go after the
world's biggest problems 1 exponential
company 1 exponential leader is travis
kalanick the CEO of uber and if we look
at uber as a company what is effectively
doing its d monetizing and d
materializing cars when uber has its
full vision implemented you don't need a
car anymore that car has d materialized
onto an app on your phone when you need
a car you click on the app and a car
shows up and takes you on it where you
want to go today there's a driver in it
I know that Travis's future plans are
for it to be you know autonomous and
they get very cost effective and all of
a sudden you don't need cars cars are a
something that's a digital asset you can
call on demand and you can use whatever
kind of car you want and of course this
D monetizes a car you don't put up
thirty or forty thousand dollars for a
car up front which by the way is idle
ninety-six percent of time you use a car
by the drink when you need it very much
like cloud computing you don't buy a
whole room of servers you use
web services when you need it on a per
you know process basis so imagine when
these physical things become
dematerialized and de monetized and all
of a sudden it's democratized because
people could not afford a car before can
now afford access to an autonomous uber
or whatever you know wherever travis
takes it down down the line and when an
exponential leader can think at this
scale to say okay how do i take a
product a service which was only
available for the wealthy few and be
able to you know digitize it
dematerialize it d monetize it and
democratize it and make it available not
for a million but for a billion people
all of a sudden even if you've dropped
the price tenfold if your markets gone
up a thousandfold you're making a
hundred times more money and this is the
future we're living in two new and this
is the kind of mindset that an
exponential leader needs to have when
they look at their business